Here's the data. This party column is the time after or before eight o'clock,
when the party starts, that you would arrive. If you arrive thirty minutes
before the party starts, so at seven thirty, then the value you get is negative
30. If you arrive an hour after the party starts at nine o'clock then your
value would be 60. When you make the chart, you're going to have to select
ranges. Since age is in column c, we want c1 to c62 then add another range. And
we want party I want i62. We also want to look at pets e1 to e62. So here we
have our scatter part. It looks like party is really spread around and pets
remains kind of consistent. It might be easier to visualize each of these
separately.